- Hi, everyone, Sal here from Khan Academy
and I just wanted to make an announcement
of something that I think
many of you will find useful.
I have a little bit of
a side project going on
called schoolhouse.world.
It isn't an official Khan Academy project,
but it's a way to get free tutoring.
Yes, I'm talking about free live tutoring.
What happens on schoolhouse.world
is you as a student
can go and say what areas
and we're starting with high school math,
what areas of high school
math you need help in
and you can see existing tutoring sessions
that are scheduled in the
coming days and coming weeks
and on the other side,
we have volunteer tutors
who look at what students,
what you, might need help in
and will schedule these
group tutoring sessions.
So whether you're interested
in being a student
and getting some free live help
or that you're interested
in being a tutor or both,
check out schoolhouse.world.
There's a little bit of
a registration process.
This is really a startup project right now
where we're trying to make sure
we balance the tutors and the students,
but I'll tell you right now
we have an incredible
number of amazing tutors
and actually we're looking
for more students to tutor.
So check it out, fill out the form
and you will be able to get some help
and the view is you can learn
at your own time and pace on Khan Academy.
Obviously we have the
exercises, the feedback there.
You have the videos.
We just launched our Get
Ready for Grade Level courses.
You can use that as well.
And then when you need in-person help,
you can go to schoolhouse.world.